Цей скромний шматок спаленої деревини має допомогти боротися із забрудненням повітря,
виробляти енергію та зменшувати викиди вуглекислого газу в атмосферу.
Це називають біовугіллям.
Звучить неймовірно, чи не так? Але дехто каже, що ажіотаж навколо цього вугілля
- це просто "зелений піар".
Що такого в біовугіллі робить його таким суперечливим?
Ми приїхали на завод біовугілля, щоб отримати деякі відповіді.
Це абсолютно новий біовугільний завод. Але він виробляє набагато більше.
Ми повернемося до цього за мить.
Біовугілля - це деревина або будь-який інший органічний матеріал,
який спалюється за температури 700-800 градусів за відсутності кисню.
Це називається піролізом.
Тепло випаровує речовини всередині біомаси.
Вони виходять назовні у вигляді горючих газів і біонафти, які можна використовувати
для виробництва енергії. А наприкінці процесу нам залишається чистий, стабільний вуглець.
Як тільки біомаса починає горіти, більшість систем можуть підтримувати себе
без використання додаткової енергії.
Як частина вуглецевого циклу планети, рослини поглинають CO2 з атмосфери
та ростуть як біомаса. Але коли вони вмирають, то розкладаються,
і більша частина вуглекислого газу, який вони всмоктали, повертається в атмосферу.
Але замість розкладання чи спалювання, якщо ми перетворимо їх на біовугілля,
то зможемо зафіксувати половину їхнього вуглецю в ґрунті чи деінде на сотні років.
Люди все більше усвідомлюють, що нам потрібно зберігати все більше і більше вуглецю.
Це Каспар Зігнер, генеральний директор компанії NovoCarbo.
Вони планують повністю запрацювати до першого кварталу 2024 року.
До того часу вони оптимізують свої системи.
Експерименти з різними способами використання біовугілля почалися протягом
останнього десятиліття. Але насправді ми виробляли деревне вугілля багатьма способами
протягом тисячоліть - від курганних до зажимних печей.
Існує багато способів виготовлення біовугілля, але не всі з них схожі на космічний корабель.
Головне, щоб всередину не потрапляв кисень.
Якщо ж потрапить, то біомаса продовжуватиме горіти, перетворюючись на попіл,
і більша частина вуглецю повернеться в атмосферу, чого ми хочемо уникнути.
Але тут процес набагато складніший.
Тому що цей завод, виробляючи біовугілля, гарантує, що всі горючі гази
повертаються в систему, щоб підтримувати високі температури
та поглинати якомога більше вуглецю.
Залежно від біомаси та процесу піролізу, до 80% вуглецю, що міститься в ній, може бути поглинуто.
Ось чому промисловість зараз представляє біовугілля як хороший спосіб
зберігання вуглекислого газу. Але не всі це підтримують.
Якщо йти цим шляхом в ім’я поглинання вуглецю та негативних викидів вуглецю,
то це створить величезний новий попит на біомасу.
Алмут Ернстінг та її команда з британської неурядової організації Biofuel Watch
стежать за дебатами та науковими даними щодо біовугілля з 2008 року.
Це неминуче означало б, що більше ґрунту перетвориться на вирощування
спеціалізованих сільськогосподарських культур і буде більше вирубки лісів,
що мало б справді руйнівний вплив на природу.
І, на жаль, ми вже бачили це деінде. Колись біопаливо вважалося екологічним джерелом енергії,
яке виробляли переважно з кукурудзи чи цукрової тростини.
Але багато експертів стверджують, що біопаливо часто може принести більше шкоди,
ніж користі через те, як ми його вирощуємо.
Критики стурбовані тим, що ми знову можемо зробити ту ж помилку з біовугіллям.
Вирубувати територію, висаджувати швидкозростаючу біомасу, подрібнювати її
та перетворювати на біовугілля, знищуючи при цьому екосистеми та біорізноманіття.
Але це необов’язково. Тому що є величезна кількість біомаси, яку ми зараз витрачаємо.
Спалювання стерні... Спалювання стерні в Північній Індії...
Згідно з нещодавнім дослідженням, лише в Індії щороку у відкритих шахтах спалюється
120 мільйонів тонн рисового лушпиння та інших сільськогосподарських відходів.
І це сильно забруднює повітря в країні, через що гине до двох мільйонів людей на рік.
За словами професорки Пріянки Каушал, біовугілля може допомогти.
Якщо ми перетворимо ці 120 мільйонів тонн на біовугілля, то отримаємо
приблизно 350 мільйонів тонн викидів CO2.
Це становить приблизно від 10 до 13% від загального обсягу
викидів парникових газів Індії.
Це було б величезним внеском у пом'якшення кліматичної кризи!
На даний момент Індія на третьому місці за рівнем викидів CO2 у світі.
А фермери, які виробляють біовугілля, могли б використовувати його
для збільшення своїх врожаїв або продавати для додаткового прибутку.
Ми пропонуємо мати невеликі мобільні підрозділи, які можуть виробляти
біовугілля на самому полі. Можливо, не на кожному полі, але, можливо,
кожен район міг би мати централізоване місце, де ви можете його виробляти.
Ви можете принести туди свої звичайні залишки і перетворити їх на вугілля.
Ми могли б відтворити це в багатьох інших місцях світу.
Оцінки того, наскільки біовугілля може зменшити викиди газів,
що спричиняють потепління клімату, без шкоди для екосистем, різняться.
Але це технологія, яка має потенціал для вирішення багатьох екологічних проблем одночасно.
Різниця між цим величезним піролізним заводом і меншими полягає в тому,
що ви можете зробити з надлишком енергії. Тут нагрівають воду і продають її в мережу.
А це дуже зручний та екологічний спосіб обігріву житла.
Інші компанії, такі як ця в Австралії, використовують надлишок енергії
для опалення теплиць і використовують біовугілля для вирощування рослин.
Деякі люди називають це вуглецевою негативною енергією,
оскільки в кінці процесу ми отримаємо вуглець, замкнений у біовугіллі.
Якщо виробляти його з місцевої надлишкової біомаси, це може бути цінним
способом виробництва енергії.
Але в кінцевому результаті це залежить від того, як ми отримуємо біомасу
і що ми з нею робимо. Якщо її транспортували за сотні кілометрів,
або якщо потрібно було вирубати ліси, або якщо це використовують
для заміни спалювання вугілля, то це вже неекологічно.
Компанія NovoCarbo може продавати гарячу воду місту, але основний продукт дістається фермерам.
В основному ми продаємо садівницьким компаніям, наразі переважно в Скандинавію.
Все більше сільськогосподарських підприємств використовують біовугілля
для покращення якості ґрунту та підвищення врожайності.
Ми бачимо, що на бідних ґрунтах це працює краще, ніж на дуже багатих ґрунтах.
А також, якщо у вас піщані ґрунти, ви зазвичай покращуєте водоутримувальну здатність.
Це Клаудія Каманн. Останні 15 років вона досліджує біовугілля.
І після більш ніж десяти років вивчення біовугілля ми знаємо з метадосліджень,
які зібрали багато знань з різних наукових праць, що ми маємо
в середньому збільшення врожайності.
Але критики кажуть, що ці "середні" результати біовугілля приховують невідповідності,
а в деяких випадках насправді завдають шкоди.
Вплив на ґрунт може бути негативним, може бути нейтральним.
У деяких випадках може бути позитивним, але насправді ніхто не може передбачити,
як це відбуватиметься.
Багато вчених кажуть, що вони не зовсім розуміють, чому біовугілля робить те,
що робить, але вони можуть виміряти результати. У багатьох випадках результат
позитивний, але вчені намагаються створити умови, за яких вплив біовугілля
був би на 100% передбачуваним.
Критики не зовсім неправі. Це не чорний чарівний порошок,
який скрізь творить одне й те саме диво.
Але зазвичай є випадки, коли він працює досить добре.
І ці випадки широко відомі. Біовугілля творить чудеса на бідних на поживні
речовини ґрунтах тропіків. Адже біовугілля має неймовірну площу поверхні.
Це прозвучить божевільно: але один грам високоякісного біовугілля
може мати більшу площу, ніж баскетбольний майданчик.
Це робить біовугілля чудовим притулком для всіх грибів,
бактерій і мікробів, необхідних для здоров’я рослин.
Він також може зберігати поживні речовини, роблячи їх доступними для рослини.
Те саме стосується води, тому що біовугілля може накопичувати
до 5 разів більше власної ваги.
Ось чому біовугілля може допомогти збільшити врожайність,
особливо на піщаних ґрунтах, які легко втрачають воду та поживні речовини.
І це також має інші дивовижні ефекти.
Закис азоту є дуже потужним парниковим газом, який має в середньому
більш ніж у 280 разів більший потенціал потепління, ніж CO2 протягом 100 років.
А закис азоту в основному утворюється з величезної кількості
добрив, які ми використовуємо.
Бактерії в ґрунті можуть розщеплювати амонійні добрива на основі нітратів на N2,
який не є парниковим газом.
Але ми вносимо стільки добрив у землю, що мікроби не можуть усе це переробити,
і воно потрапляє в атмосферу у вигляді закису азоту, що вбиває клімат.
До 75% світових викидів закису азоту припадає на сільськогосподарську діяльність.
Зараз існує кілька метадосліджень, які показують, що в середньому ми маємо
скорочення приблизно на 40% цих викидів нітратів, якщо використовувати
біовугілля в ґрунтах разом із добривами. Але в деяких виробничих дослідженнях,
які ми провели в Університеті Гейзенгайму, ми спостерігали зниження на 80%.
Зменшення від 40 до 80% газу, що вбиває клімат! Це дійсно багатообіцяюче!
Та повернімося на узбережжя Балтійського моря.
NovoCarbo шукає повернення своїх значних інвестицій у розмірі 8,5 мільйонів євро.
Ось чому вони також продають інший продукт, який є дещо суперечливим.
Виробляючи біовугілля, наш основний продукт, ми використовуємо його для застосування,
наприклад, у ґрунті, для покращення ґрунту.
Після внесення біовугілля в ґрунт можна надати вуглецевий кредит,
оскільки ми постійно зберігаємо вуглець, біовугілля в ґрунті, а потім його там фіксуємо.
Ми виробляємо на цьому місці приблизно 1700 тонн біовугілля на рік,
а це означає приблизно 3200 тонн CO2.
Це еквівалентно приблизно тому, що в середньому викидають 400 німців на рік.
Це небагато, але це початок.
Система купівлі вуглецевих кредитів для балансування викидів може бути суперечливою,
і ми присвятили цілий сюжет цій темі.
Обов’язково подивіться, якщо хочете розібратися.
Але окрім вуглецевих кредитів, біовугілля виглядає дуже багатообіцяючим способом
вирішення багатьох проблем, пов’язаних із кліматом, з якими ми стикаємося сьогодні:
від збагачення ґрунту та збільшення врожайності до зменшення CO2
та закису азоту в атмосфері. Це може допомогти нам використовувати менше добрив і води.
Ми навіть не згадали про інші потенційні способи використання біовугілля,
наприклад, у бетоні, що може зменшити вуглецевий слід від будівництва.
Але біовугілля містить велике застереження: воно корисний лише тоді,
коли у нас є багато місцевої біомаси, яка так чи інакше витрачається.
Ось чому ми зосереджуємося на потоках відходів і розглядаємо всі ці підходи
до економіки замкнутого циклу, які ми маємо.
У майбутньому буде набагато більше доступної біомаси.
Але представлення біовугілля як глобального вирішення всіх наших кліматичних проблем -
це лише ще один спосіб, щоб спробувати знайти прості рішення наших складних проблем.
Що ви думаєте про біовугілля? Чи може воно бути хорошим інструментом
для пом’якшення кліматичної кризи? Ви б почали його використовувати?